the Israeli military's nightly raids and
Detention of Palestinians in the
occupied West Bank continued in the
early hours of Sunday Palestinian
Fighters exchanged gunfire with soldiers
in the city of nabas in the north there
were also clashes between Palestinians
and Israeli forces in the city of tulam
well Ellen Fisher has more for us uh
from occupied East Jerusalem and Ellen
as we saw there another night of Israeli
raids in the occupied West Bank some uh
looking more violent than usual as they
met stiff
resistance well I think the argument
that they look more violent and usual
would be disputed by the people who are
on the ground and have' been suffering
this since October the 7th in Nabis a
number of rests were recorded north of
Hebron we're certainly hearing that a
teacher was among those arrested someone
who is identified locally as a teacher
but as you say the worst of the exchange
is definitely in Tulum uh what we're
hearing is that around 40 Israeli
military vehicles including bulldozers
drove in to taram there they started to
break the main water supply leading into
the refugee camp at that area there were
then some clashes and the Israeli forces
came under Fire from armed Palestinian
Fighters the Israelis then started to
put snipers onto the roof and there were
intense but sporadic exchanges between
both sides the Israelis uh surrounded a
house and through loudspeakers ordered
the people to give up and indeed there
were a number of arrests but this is the
continuing pattern of what we've seen in
the West Bank since October the 7th with
more than 4,600 arrests and more than
300 people dead in Ellen the Israeli
Army's just given an update on the death
of its soldiers in the Gaza
Strip on Saturday they announced that
five had actually died in Gaza on
Saturday that has been updated twice in
the last couple of hours first of all to
eight and the numbers included four who
were killed in fighting in southern Gaza
and also in Northern Gaza but that
figure has now also been updated to 13
which is the largest number of deaths
announced by the Israelis in any single
day since October the 7th the Israeli
Army Daniel hagari who is the main
spokesman saying that the number of
people dead were dead because they had
been targeted by missiles they had been
victims of an explosion and he also
pointed to the fact that there has been
intense fighting in areas like can
yunits and that has been continuing
throughout all of Saturday and into
Sunday and of course we're hearing from
the Israelis that they are committed to
this phase of the war even under us
pressure now the US may want them to
wrap it up sooner rather than later but
we are now two weeks on from when we
heard that from the Americans one week
on from Lloyd Austin's visit and clearly
the Israelis are continuing to push with
the same intensity we've seen over the
last several weeks certainly seems that
way thanks so much that's Ellen Fisher
for us in occupied East
Jerusalem